if i keep that routine
for three minutes
no stress can keep on because i have to
control
i have to
integrate motion
and phys in in movement breathing and
movement together
and as i
start to play on this
nothing can be like i cannot thinking
about oh the time to travel i have to go
to san diego tomorrow i have to give my
daughter whatever it is
you have to refresh it because the way
you breed you can really clean your mind
the way you breed you can lower your
heart rates
for fighting for example i was doing
like i get an event
three hours before the event
my fight
so i go to the locker room sleep for
hour and a half hour 40 minutes by will
i just breathing my relaxed breathing i
can sleep deeply
wake up one hour before the fight
mourn myself up for 45 minutes
putting my heartbeat my heart rates to
160 140 to really break the sweat and
make sure i'm cool
and then sit for five minutes and bring
my heart rate to 6500 heartbeats a
minute
so i was deeply raw hot
ready to go with my heartbeat
so i see my other opponent in the other
side of the ring jumping around he's
already 85 90.
so when i engage i engage not to
to to make some kind of nice uh
rhythm i try to to improve press the gas
and let's go for power
so we do everything we can do so if i'm
struggle you cannot rest you have to
keep up with me so
when i'm 80 you 110 when i'm 110 150
when we're 100 when i'm 150 you're
already trying to i had a heart attack
yeah
so you start to regroup and start
seeking for air and that's time normally
where mistakes happen and i really make
the
close the deal
so breathing become my best friend not
only to control my emotions to keep my
my
my heart rate and the best performance
to recoup
so to be controlling panic controlling
emotions
become calm to strategize everything
coming from this capacity within to
control yourself by breathing so i felt
like was a great
addition to my
my practice and makes a huge change in
my life
this is something that i i connected the
dots on a few years ago
because people would ask me i would say
listen when things are going bad you
have to stay calm you have to you have
to learn how to you know control your
emotions and and don't get all excited
about something when things are going
wrong
and people would say well you know how
do you do it
and one of the things that i realized
that i would do is
so in the military you know you have a
radio with you and when you when you
talk on the radio everybody can hear you
and in the military
it's very frowned upon
if you get on the radio and you are
emotional if you scream
help over here if you panic like this
so
every time i ever talked on the radio
my goal was to never sound panicked
never sound emotional no matter what was
going on
sound very calm and cool
so that means whenever things were going
crazy and i was about to have to get on
the radio what would i have to do i had
to breathe i had to take a breath
and so it's the same thing it's just
that something that i was doing so that
i could you know i'd be oh there's got
stuff going on right okay i'm about
talking radio
hey this is jocko we need about 10 more
guys down at this building right now and
that
me taking control of my of my breath
also would help me
get into a controlled emotional state
where i'm not losing my mind yes
that's very powerful
from jiu jitsu yes because you know the
the the breathing system or because you
stay seven days without food you stay
three days without water five minutes
without oxygen is already dead
yes
so the efficiency of the breeding system
is very needed and people
take this for granted they don't oh i i
i born i get slapped on the butt
and you're alive and well and you can
live like if you don't train in
breathing it's like your biceps it's
like your your your
strategies your techniques your
if you don't train in the breathing
system you're going to work with 40
percent less the capacity capabilities
to really
refresh yourself hyperventilate
bringing yourself to a next level of
understanding because
if you get tired and you don't know how
to hyperventilate you get tired and your
mind starts to face
to fade a little bit you start to making
poor decisions you start to get
completely off your game because it's no
oxygen enough for the brain and the in
the body
but if you know how to hyperventilate
you can have cramps that's the lattice
all over you cannot even move well very
tired but your brain is too sharp you
can see details you can see the girls
smile at you you can see the super bowl
you can see everything you want to see
and talk because your brain is still
fresh
and that's the capacity you have to
learning how to hyperventilate and use
the diaphragmatic breathing
which improve improves your life like a
tone